pretty
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i've
been using the lpx 13d
build of android 5.0 lollipop on my
nexus 5 for the past couple of days and
surprise i really like it a couple weeks
ago i showcased an earlier build of
android 5.0 the developer preview back
on it was just known as android l but
now with lollipop there are a lot of new
features and this build is as close as
we have now to final so this is a
rundown of a lot of the new awesome
features that i think people are gonna
like so right off the bat two words
you're going to hear a lot when it comes
to android 5.0 are material design and
while that's an entire redesign of all
of android you can probably sum it up
best in one word which would be
animations basically everything you
touch brings something onto the screen
or moves it off so you know exactly
where things are coming from and where
they're going and that's the whole point
so the straight up unlock screen here or
just unlocking into the dialer will give
you an animation or unlocking into the
camera and you can see the animation
shows what you're doing isn't just
popping out of nowhere it's coming from
somewhere
and same with the new app drawer it
springs to life out of that button
instead of fading in out of nowhere like
before and you'll see a lot more
transitions and animations all over the
place in lollipop just like this so it
keeps with the whole theme and i
actually consider that a feature it's
legitimately helping with creating an
intuitive ui although it still doesn't
help that the back button in android is
still just as inconsistent as it has
been in previous versions but there are
a lot more helpful animations that
you'll notice every time you pick up the
phone which is really cool and it's also
awesome to see these animations really
always running at a pretty high decent
frame rate especially since this is a
nexus 5 a one year old phone and
hopefully android l on older devices or
lower end ones will still be just this
fast at least i hope so so if you're
thinking nexus 6 is going to be too big
looks like nexus 5 is beginning to look
like a steal at under 400 bucks so first
off there's a new google launcher app
drawer and wallpapers now all material
design themed if that makes any sense i
already showed you the app drawer
animation but check out these new
wallpapers here too some of them are
pretty sweet looking
and i have my favorites but i'll link a
downloadable album in the description
right below that like button if you want
to check them out too uh next is the
notification area which has also been
redone so you can see all your
notifications and obviously all the same
functionality as before but now you have
a clear all button which was gone in the
previous build so thank gosh it's back
and you have another swipe down to get
into your quick settings or two finger
swipe if you want so you have your
brightness slider which wasn't there
before that was another click away and
you also have wi-fi and bluetooth
toggles etc some new stuff here that
wasn't in kitkat you have a flashlight
toggle which is new very nice and a
screen orientation lock again very
useful for many
and a screencast button which will allow
you to screencast to a tv if you have a
chromecast also that second swipe down
reveals a bunch of information with that
smooth animation again
showing you your time a clickable alarm
text a clickable battery percentage to
show your battery settings a clickable
shortcut to settings and a profile
switcher so now you can have multiple
profiles on android on your phone just
like you could on a tablet if you share
one and you can have two people signed
in three people signed in or if you want
to just let someone borrow your phone
for a day or something give him that
guest account which is basically just
like you got a brand new phone no apps
or anything are installed they can pick
their own apps to install and they don't
see any of your media and then you can
just password protect your main account
and you're good but if you switch back
that'll actually show you that when you
get to your lock screen the lock screen
also now shows notifications which is
pretty cool it's just like in ios
except swiping them away here doesn't
open them and dismisses them if you want
to open one you actually have to double
tap it to open the app so here's another
trick with the notification area you can
hold down any notification to see what
app is showing it and then you can go
into that app and go to the app settings
to change whether or not that app can
show you any more really useful if some
game keeps pestering you to buy the
premium version or something annoying
like that there's also now a shortcut to
three different do not disturb modes
when you tap the volume button so if you
leave all that's just normal just
continues to show all notifications
priority will only show the most
important notifications and your alarms
and when you switch to none that will
not let anything through not even alarms
it totally silences your phone so you
can pick the amount of time it stays in
that mode so if you have a 45 minute
commute you can have it silenced for the
hour that you're driving and then it
automatically turns off also you can
choose what priority mode includes so
you can choose to have text messages
included or calls included basically
customize it to your liking i always
leave on priority mode when i go to
sleep so that the only thing that can
wake me up is my alarm so there's also
new look inside some of the stock apps
in android 5.0 the dialer looks very
material design-y it's super round super
flat
there are animations everywhere there's
a new in-call look so if you call
someone
and it looks pretty clean the one thing
i don't like is that the hang up button
is now way smaller i actually liked it
when it was a huge full screen thing so
i could just end the call without
thinking but i guess i'll have to get
used to the smaller centered one and
there are other little things all around
android 5.0 really that you might not
even notice for a while even using the
phone a fun one is that the screen off
animation is actually very very slowly
fading to black and white before it
turns off your display pretty damn cool
that you may not even notice for a while
the new setup process in android 5 is a
lot easier when you first sign into your
google account for the first time
especially if you have two-step
authentication that is a huge
improvement android beam now allows you
to share any file type where you can
only really share links and images
before and the keyboard in android is
redesigned and the letter presses look a
little bit different from before as well
you can also use nfc or bluetooth
devices like smartwatches for example as
a trusted device to let you bypass your
lock password they call this smart lock
and it works very well i use it with my
moto 360 all the time and also now if
you have multiple google chrome tabs
open all of them will show up as
separate activities in your multitasking
carousel so you can open them up or
close them by swiping away one by one in
here oh and you also notice they kept
google search available in the
multitasking menu as well i don't know
how useful that is but it's there the
new clock believe it or not the clock
app changes the color of the background
depending on the time of day so if
you're in the middle of the day when the
sun's out it matches the sky and it's
all blue at night it goes dark purple
etc i think that's pretty neat
and there's now a battery saver mode
that prompts you to turn itself on at
about 15
and once you turn the battery saver mode
on your notification bar and bottom nav
bar turn bright orange so you can't
accidentally forget you have the mode on
and this will turn off most of your
background data it turns the vibration
motor off basically turns your phone
into a local media player but hey it
gets you an extra hour or so out of the
end of your battery which can be useful
for a lot of people now here's one more
really good one screen pinning so let's
say your friend wants to borrow your
phone and say hey dude let me borrow
your phone i just want to make a call
and i trust you friend i trust that
you're gonna just borrow my phone and
make a call and not buy a three thousand
dollar paper shredder on amazon two
minutes later but if i can guarantee
that if i can guarantee you only use the
phone then that would be really nice so
if you go into security settings and
enable screen pinning you can then go
into your multitasking app pick the app
you want to screen pin let's say the
dialer and then you can pin that app to
be the only app that you can use so then
you can confidently hand him your phone
knowing that he can't get out of the
dialer or do anything else crazy he can
just call someone and that's it of
course assuming he doesn't know how to
exit screen pinning mode which is a long
press of the back and recent apps button
at the same time but honestly he
probably won't and i mean imagine
handing this to a kid or something with
a game screen pinned that sounds like
endless entertainment to me so in
summary it seems like android l is
coming along really well uh i was at
first worried about the lighter look
everything seems to be bright white or
very pale and light looking compared to
the total opposite which would be hollow
of android 4.0 which was all dark so
it's something we need to get used to
but other than that i'm liking a lot of
what i'm seeing in android l and i can't
wait to see the final final version on
the nexus 6 and the nexus 9. but until
then i'm going to leave it at that i
can't wait to get the new hardware in
hand thank you for watching leave a
thumbs up if you enjoyed i'll talk to
you guys in the next video
peace